community park on 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
it's a local non-profit that's been
providing emergency housing and food to
people since 1991 talking about Hope
link of Southern Nevada to talk more
about that we're joined by Tyler quarter
of Findlay automotive the sponsors of
this segment and Stacy Lockhart the CEO
of hopelink of Southern Nevada thank you
both for being here today thanks for
having us Tyler why is it so important
to be associated with hopelink so you
know we get involved with a lot of
Charities but I really like what
hopelink does because number one they're
a local charity as you mentioned been
here over 30 years in Las Vegas but they
don't just treat the symptoms of
homelessness there's a lot of
organizations that will provide a meal
or a shelter for the night type of thing
but you still need to do that again
tomorrow what what hopelink does is
really tries to get to the point of
preventing homelessness when someone's
in a crisis and looks like they're going
to lose their housing or whatever that's
where hopelink steps in and helps them
and gets them into a sustainable
situation so that's what we really like
about it that's why I wanted to bring
Stacy on and we'll talk a little bit
about it yeah Stacy would people be
surprised to or maybe not to discover
how much need is out there
so you know and covid just made us even
more
than we've ever been there's so many
households out there that were on that
Brink you know housing and security and
almost losing their housing so we really
stepped in there I mean we spent 10
million in five months keeping people in
their homes during coven but I thought
we'd get a breather and it hasn't
happened we our phones ring off the hook
people are filling our lobby you know
the need is really there the gas prices
the food prices the rent increases it
just hasn't let up so is your budget
around 10 million it's about thirteen
five now and three years ago it was 1.2
holy cow are you getting that obviously
sponsorships like Findlay automotive but
also grants we do we have a lot of great
Partners Clark County the city of
Henderson's an amazing partner North Las
Vegas HUD and then uh we raise money
through private grants and you know
individual private philanthropy from
from people like you and me that really
care about what we're doing it's such
great work and Tyler you guys are also
helping support the golf tournament
that's coming up yeah so uh this this
could be the second annual golf
tournament uh LinkedIn
like that last year we went out we were
sponsoring it uh and uh this year we're
on again it's coming up on March 10th
out of chimera golf course in Henderson
which is a great course if you haven't
played there so yeah we're looking
forward to it and hoping that we can
raise it we really want to make this a
signature fundraiser for for Hope link
every year are you both playing are you
just going to be out there no no no I'm
hosted
once again where can people go to sign
up for that golf tournament uh www link
the number two hope.org okay uh
everything's up on our website um our
social media Facebook LinkedIn uh hope
link of Southern Nevada we've been
sharing information there as well and we
have links to that on our site as well
so Stacy and Tyler thank you both for
being here today really appreciate it
thank you so much Mercedes